[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
welcome to the bonus show President Joe
Biden is releasing 15 million barrels
from the Strategic oil Reserve to try to
tame gas prices as the case may be now
one thing I think is interesting to
mention is we haven't really been
following the trajectory of gas prices
over the last little bit of time we had
this big big spike that peaked right
around mid-june where the national
average hit five dollars and two cents
then we saw a dramatic decline down to
about four dollars a gallon by the
beginning of August prices continue down
but more slowly down to sort of between
the middle and end of September around
370 a gallon and then prices have kind
of gone up and down and one of the
things that's important to remember is
it's normal for the prices to go up and
down and I think one of the things
that's happening Pat and we'll get to
this to the Strategic oil Reserve in a
moment is
typically we don't watch gas prices as
closely as maybe we have over the last
year and a half it's really common that
they'll go up 20 cents and down 20 cents
because people are watching them so
closely over the last month and a half
or even less than that even last month
we've seen prices go down to about 370
then up to 395 now back down to about
380 or so this is actually normal this
is not necessarily indicative that you
have to do anything in particular right
gas prices and the two range the three
range that's pretty much what we're used
to I think we all just have this shell
shock from the fact that it hit five
dollars a gallon on average over the
summer and we're all worried that it
could get back up to there so once if
and when it does hit the fours again I
think there'll be a lot more movement to
you know raise concern about this sort
of thing but if things level out around
here that's not too crazy uh it just
kind of plays into this picture of
inflation and these other Rising costs
concerns yeah three dollars and fifty
sixty cents that's not too bad I get the
sense and I don't I don't know I get the
sense that this is being done
for more for the Optics of number one
being seen as doing something and number
two just getting a lower sticker price
on gas more than it is out of any real
economic need I mean 15 million more
barrels I don't think it's going to do
much to the price first of all and what
it does do will be relatively temporary
I never want to write off the impact of
a few cents per gallon but the truth is
for most people's budgets a few cents
per gallon really doesn't make a
difference in whether you can make it to
the end of the month or not it's just
math I'm not ignoring the financial
plight of anybody it's just it's really
not that much I am sort of wondering
whether this is more about hey here's
something to announce in advance of the
midterms which will have a little impact
and it will be more for Optics than for
real economic changes right based on our
previous calculations removing some oil
from the Strategic petroleum Reserve
will lower gas prices by about 10 15
cents which is not going to make the
difference in people's budget it's like
maybe whenever you fill up your car
instead of having to pay 80 bucks you
have to pay uh 77 bucks something like
that yeah dollars of savings and it I
guess it adds up but not to a tremendous
amount I think it is more about seeing
that sticker price and seeing the
trajectory because people want to see
that go down over time yeah and then you
talk about the politics of it that is
the big criticism about this that Biden
is trying to buy votes for Democrats in
the midterms but I think any Republican
that's levying that charge is ignoring
the fact that they do that too on their
side they do it with tax cuts uh Trump
right before the 2020 election passed
that stimulus bill that gave people like
600 checks what is that if not trying to
buy votes so you can make the argument I
suppose but you're guilty of it too on
your side no doubt about it so let's see
what this does if anything uh I mean I I
also just I just don't know that voters
are going to make the connection between
Biden announcing this to be done in
December and voting for a Democrat for
Senate in your state I just don't know
that voters are making that connection I
I don't think they're making the
connection with Biden releasing the oil
but they may make the connection with
the gas prices going down so I think
that's the thing that they're trying to
focus on I guess the issue is if this
won't take effect till December it's
after the election but listen we'll see
we'll see what if and what happens with
the prices and if and what happens with
polling and then we'll see if there's
sort of any any connection there
um Madison cawthorne the radical
republican congressman who was defeated
after just one term not even I mean in
the primary during his first term and
will thankfully be leaving Congress he
is going to stand trial in January for
allegedly bringing a loaded gun to an
airport now you might be saying which
time because this has actually happened
more than once Madison cawthorne has a
court date January 13th related to the
charges for this incident where he
allegedly brought a loaded gun
to the airport
um this is
um a possession of a dangerous weapon on
city property this happened at
Charlotte's International Airport in
April he was released in standard
protocol not uh it is not typical he
didn't get special treatment in not
getting pre-trial detention for this
charge it is typical that would
discharge you or you were released after
the handgun is confiscated and he has
yet to enter a plea on Instagram he said
the day after the incident I made a
mistake it's just a flat out mistake of
course it's the second time he made the
mistake because in February of 2021 TSA
agents at Asheville North Carolina's
airport also found him with a Glock nine
millimeter pistol no criminal charges
took place then this time there are
charges and the trial date has been set
you know I don't know that I have a
strong feeling Pat about like what
should happen here there is a kind of
viral police body cam video that's out
there when this happened to just a
random guy I don't even remember what
airport it was it might have been in
Georgia I just I just don't remember a
guy had a gun uh in his luggage and TSA
found it they brought police the guy was
completely apologetic and it was just
chalked up to a mistake no charges were
filed the law enforcement kept the gun
at the airport until the guy returned
from his trip and then he was able to
pick it up am I out for blood and I
think that guy should necessarily be
charged I don't really know the answer
and the reason I say that is I believe I
don't know about cawthorne the video I
saw
this guy clearly was not trying to get a
gun uh onto the plane he just the guy
just didn't know where it was not
knowing where your gun is is a form of
negligence with a with a tool that could
kill people so like we do need to take
that seriously but it is obvious that it
was just a mistake I I just don't know I
don't know what should be done in these
cases I'm very much uh sympathetic
towards giving a warning on the first
time especially because like
it's one of those things where you live
in a state where you're able to have a
gun on you you can conceal carry you may
just be used to bringing it around with
you everywhere at the airport culture
there it is crazy but I suppose that it
can happen and people I know that
ignorance of the law is no excuse but
people could be unaware and if it's
there's no like malice if there's no bad
intention with it I kind of get the idea
that maybe you should not charge and say
okay this is a warning don't do this
again this is very much illegal where
I'll keep the gun and when you return
we'll give it back to you but with
Madison cother and he did it twice it's
not the first time right with the second
time I do think that a misdemeanor
charge makes sense here he should have
to go through the criminal process
because he should have known better by
that second time and maybe there's an
element of hubris to it where he figures
oh I'm allowed to have a gun on me
because it's my constitutional right or
maybe he figures I'm a congressman so I
can do this or I got away with it the
last time so what's the big deal
and I I just get the sense that with
most people they're not trying to do
this with any bad intent and so you give
a warning on the first time yeah I I'm
you know one of the things I have talked
about a lot is two Justice systems and
this type of leniency often isn't given
even on drug charges and I don't want to
sound like I'm the guy saying oh give
leniency to the mostly white dudes with
the guns at the airport and then throw
the drug users or low-level dealers in
jail like I I'm not I'm not trying to do
any of that I'm just thinking out loud
about okay like we need to do something
so that it's taken more seriously you
can't just show up at the airport with
the gun like without a doubt I just am
thinking out loud about how far we
should be going I don't know well yeah
when dealing with the two-tier justice
system I suppose there's two approaches
one is to throw the book at everyone and
be entirely strict so you treat people
equally that way the other is to be
lenient towards these sorts of things or
at least err on the side of leniency
whenever possible and you administer
that leniency when it comes to white
people and black people like collar
people and blue collar people you know
all these different types of groups and
I tend to go with that that second
option there when it comes to drugs when
it comes to guns these sorts of things I
just tend to think that we over
criminalize too much in this society as
it is and warnings should be they have
their place and sometimes with a case
like this that's what you want to go
with let us know what you think and
again just because you could have one
opinion about Madison carthorne because
it's the second time and a different
opinion about the first time this
happens or not let us know and we will
do a follow-up hey this is a crazy story
from the old stomping grounds of the
David packman show in Western
Massachusetts a woman is being charged
with sending a swarm of bees at police
deputies at an eviction that took place
this is a crazy story and so many of my
friends from where I grew up have been
posting about this to Facebook so here's
here's the story as reported by the
Associated Press a Massachusetts woman
who released a swarm of bees at
sheriff's deputies as they tried to
serve an eviction notice has now been
charged with multiple counts of assault
and battery
this is 55 year old Rory woods and you
can actually find a picture of her
getting arrested she's literally wearing
a beekeeper's suit in the arrest I mean
just every the imagery is an un it's
unbelievable you can find the the
Associated Press article she pleaded not
guilty at her arraignment on October
12th in Springfield Massachusetts
District Court released without bail
um she and other protesters say we were
trying to prevent a wrongful eviction
the homeowner brought evidence of a
bankruptcy a stay to court the next day
at which point everything should have
stopped
and it didn't stop so she says and the
police still showed up and tried to
evict her and Hampden County deputies
say when they went to the home in
question on the morning of the eviction
they were met by protesters that Woods
who lives in Hadley was one of the
protesters arrived in an SUV towing a
trailer carrying beehives and started
shaking the beehives in order to release
the bees and causing hundreds of bees to
swarm out and reportedly sting one
deputy and I'm sort of laughing but this
is crazy I mean this is crazy behavior
Woods knowing that this was the plan
showed up wearing a beekeeper's outfit
in order to protect herself and was
eventually handcuffed but not uh before
more Sheriff's Department employees were
stung including three who were allergic
to bees she reportedly said oh you're
allergic good
this is a crazy crazy thing to do it's
definitely creative it's thinking
outside of the box but it's also a
serious crime and yeah that when most
people think about assault and battery
they think about one person wailing on
another like physical strikes punches
kicks that sort of thing they don't
think about these other types of things
that could be assault like unleashing a
bunch of bees at people or tear gas or
throwing something at somebody and yeah
she's definitely not helping her case by
saying oh you're allergic to the bees
that's good that's that's got to make
things a little bit more severe because
that could potentially be deadly for
those people who are allergic hopefully
that an EpiPen by uh but yeah this is an
absolutely crazy story and uh no wonder
why you you came from this part yes
exactly now I I I don't I'm gonna just
throw something else out there to see
what you think about this
um
on average not on average out of the
total population somewhere between five
and seven percent of the American
population is believed to be allergic to
bee stings now that doesn't mean you go
into anaphylactic shock and immediately
need to be hit with an EpiPen but it's
some degree of allergy
um given that
should there not be I'm not talking
about attempted murder but I'm just
saying is this a more serious crime than
it might seem because of that I think so
yeah I absolutely do think so and I
wonder if the numbers matter to assess
that calculation because like if there's
just one cop there's a five to seven
percent chance that they are allergic
but if you have a group of 20 tops then
yeah there's probably a significant
chance that at least one of those cops
is allergic so does that mean that the
crime that you get charged with should
be more severe just given the odds of
that I think so and um yeah that's why
it's a lot more serious than it leads on
like we were laughing about the details
of the story because it is so bizarre
and who would think to do something like
this but there is a serious component to
this where someone could actually die
from it let's I mean think about a
different scenario right like let's see
how common is well soy allergy isn't
that what's another food allergy that's
peanuts peanut okay how common is peanut
allergy peanut allergy is uh one in 200
adults okay so imagine I'm just throwing
this out there's a large restaurant that
seats 200 adults in a night imagine that
someone secretly goes in and sprinkles
peanut powder over all 200 entrees
meaning that statistically there's one
adult in there who's allergic is is that
more of a crime than just like I don't
know tampering with food because
statistically one out of those 200
people has a has a peanut allergy I
don't know I don't know I think it would
be I mean I think you're you're playing
with the numbers there there's some risk
that you know that you're taking on by
doing something like that yeah you know
that you're choosing the peanut oil for
a reason as opposed to something else
that you want to Tamper the food with my
sense is that it is yeah I mean it's
it's a random attack it's almost like
terrorism in a way you know who's gonna
get hit hardest by it I was recently I
recently read
um Richard Preston's book demon in the
freezer which is about uh let me think
if I recall it's about smallpox
um
Ebola
Anthrax including the anthrax attacks
around 911 small pox Ebola Anthrax and
something else anyway
um the volatility and contagiousness of
some of these uh agents is truly scary I
mean reading about you do we talk about
if you are Celiac and you go into a
pizza place and there could like if
you're if I'm not talking about oh I'm
gluten-free second you actually have
serious Celiac you can become very ill
just from going into a pizzeria where
there is a flower flying in the air some
of this stuff like smallpox is so
contagious it's the the the the the P
the what are the elements the pieces of
it are so volatile that almost with no
wind they can just get sucked through
HVAC systems it's it's crazy how
contagious some of this stuff is yeah
we're lucky to not have any severe
allergy like that that would be
absolutely wild yeah and I have to ask
why is the book titled that
it's because for a period of time the
last remaining smallpox was sitting in a
couple freezers and there was this big
debate including during the Clinton era
do we destroy the last smallpox or do we
keep it in case we need because we don't
know for sure that there's no smallpox
left a repository somewhere what if we
need to develop a vaccine we might need
what's remaining of the smallpox and so
it's in the freezer so to speak what did
they ultimately decide that's quite the
ethical dilemma Bill Clinton ultimately
decided not to destroy it and to be
honest I'd the book stops 20 years ago
the book is from 2002. I don't know what
the state is now of those smallpox
reserves now given the uh lably
conspiracy theory there's uh probably
some debate that's been rehashed over
that whether they should get rid of that
let's see there are two who designated
stocks where it is still stored and used
for research so it seems it was not
destroyed
not destroyed all right well that's
going to feed into a lot of conspiracies
then maybe so they unleashed the Wuhan
virus on us and next they're going to do
it with smallpox yeah and the book talks
about by the way at the point at which
there was the discussion of destroying
it
inspectors realized Russia was doing
like smallpox amplification and
modification studies and that was a big
factor in saying we shouldn't destroy
this because given that Russia is
messing around with it we really may
need to develop a vaccine again at some
point there's always an Armor's race
isn't there yeah whether it comes to
space to nuclear weapons to now smallpox
in this way I do recommend the book to
you though and actually Richard Preston
has a lot of other good books one just
focused on Ebola and uh many many others
all right we'll see everybody tomorrow a
new show new bonus show